les canadiens veulent un pays où la
justice
la véritable justice est au coeur de
notre système juridique ou légale ibra
est établi entre l'espoir de
préméditation
l'imposition de peines appropriées et la
prévention avec compassion envers les
gens respectueux de la loi et leur
famille et en particulier envers les
victimes des crimes les plus odieux gris
les critiques stephen harper va donc de
l'avant avec son projet de loi sur la
détention à vie sans possibilité de
libération conditionnelle avant non plus
25 ans comme c'est le cas actuellement
mais bien 35 ans pour certains criminels
qui ont commis des meurtres de nature
particulièrement violente
cette nouvelle mesure législative est
elle nécessaire ou est-elle
électoralistes tasha et daniel sont à
ottawa ce soir et c'est sébastien qui
est là avec nous puisque michel est en
vacances bienvenue sébastien les soirs à
vous trois tasha je commence avec vous
ce projet de loi est il vraiment
nécessaire est ce qu'il répond à un
problème réel mais il ya un problème je
pense qu'ils aient dans les nouvelles
récemment il ya trois cas en particulier
qui sont sortis dont le cas le plus
notamment de vince li à winnipeg qui tu
es quelqu'un dans un autobus greyhound
de façon très barbaric dambach pardon
qui va être en libération avec cette
condition b
il a obtenu un droit de sortie laser
seront réservées et lui je pense que ça
touche et une heure chez la population
est ce que beaucoup de personnes qui
sont visés par cette loi nyon alors
c'est pas un problème réel dans le sens
qui est un problème énorme mais je pense
être un problème réel à la conscience de
beaucoup de canadiens et donc ça le
gouvernement avait promis d'agir sur ce
fait là et ils agissent maintenant en
limitant la possibilité de deux sorties
conditionnelle justement vince il avait
été quand même déclaré non
criminellement responsable oui c'est ça
daniel fraysse nécessaire ce projet de
loi écoutez j'ai pas beaucoup de
sympathie pour ce genre de criminels
ceux qui commettent comme disait le
premier ministre les crimes odieux
je vais pas pleurer pour pour eux sauf
que les possibilités que les bernardo
pecten de ce monde se retrouvent en
liberté ou un jour surtout à peu près
nulle parce que en 2010 on a modifié la
loi pour faire en sorte qu'il reste en
prison quasiment jusqu'à la fin de leur
vie alors à quoi va servir cette
nouvelle voie à je ne sais pas
exactement je connais les raisons les
motivations électorale du 1er mai après
son très hésitante mais dans les faits
la john howard society expliqué
aujourd'hui de toute récidive chez le
meurtrier au canada varie entre 1 et 2%
c'est quand même pas énorme ça se
compare à six qui se fait dans d'autres
sociétés comme le canada c'est sûrement
pire aux etats unis j'ai pas vu deux
chefs de ce côté là exc c'est un projet
de loi électorale et des élections qui
s'en viennent me sur un peu avec le
terrorisme
avec ce projet doit cette semaine et
probablement la vidéo qui sera rendu
public demain de l'auteur de l'attentât
au parlement qui va frapper l'imaginaire
des canadiens il est en train de créer
un climat d'insécurité je dirais même de
peur jusqu'à un certain point
sébastien qu'est ce que vous voyez
derrière ce projet de loi évidemment une
volonté du gouvernement de répondre à
des préoccupations des jeunes la
population qui de façon relativement
légitime pense qu'il peut y avoir des
attentats terroristes ou encore que des
criminels pour s attaquer à des
policiers donc on veut répondre à ça en
même temps on est en train de modifier
un peu les fondements ou le paradigme
système carcéral canadien dans la mesure
où évidemment un des fondements c'est la
punition punir les
une aile les meurtriers les assassins
des violeurs les voleurs aussi mais un
des paradigmes de notre système carcéral
c'est aussi la réhabilitation alors
est-ce qu'on n'est pas en train
d'envoyer un message que au bout de 25
ans on était incapable de réhabiliter
des criminels dangereux
le système carcéral a fait la
démonstration que dans la vaste majorité
des cas les gens qui sortent au bout de
25 ans et qui sont pas facilement
nécessairement lors qu'en mon nom dans
un moulin ces gens là sont
irrécupérables ce qui dans les faits
n'est pas tout à fait vrai achat mais
c'est justement ce point là sébastien
sur lequel le premier ministre a touché
quand il a fait l'annoncé il a dit que
le gouvernement désire l'art et la
réhabilitation mais dans certains cas
c'est la sécurité publique on peut pas
permettre même une personne qui pourrait
commettre un autre meurtre de sortir de
prison alors c'est vraiment dans ce sens
là je pense la sécurité qui vient de
l'avant comme daniel a dit c'est un
climat où les conservateurs se
positionne comme le parti qui est mieux
pour assurer la sécurité contre les
terroristes et criminelles n'importe qui
qui menace la société met sa touche
quand même très peu de gens attachants
oui ça touche très peu de gens mais
comment dit dans dans l'imagination la
perception du public
les cas qui font les manchettes sont
tellement affreux qu' il y à la
perception que c'est une menace très
suivi des cours nelly bernardo vont
rester en prison pratiquement jusqu'à la
fin de leurs jours le système actuel
dans le fond permet de garder en prison
si je comprends bien des personnages
comme ça des criminels dangereux comme
se voyait après 35 ans daniel ils
pourront demander une libération
conditionnelle au ministre de la
sécurité publique c'est dans ce cabinet
fédéral qui va décider
est ce que c'est la désaveu de la
commission des libérations
conditionnelles
écoutez la commission des libérations
conditionnelles l'été l'objet de moult
crise et qu'est-ce qu'elle fait un beau
travail dans l'ensemble on pense que oui
sauf que ces décisions là ça ne se prend
pas de face aux techniques de façon
scientifique se demander si on peut
libérer
prisonnier le laisser sortir de temps à
eau c'est une question d'évaluation
c'est des humains qui font des
évaluations il leur arrive de se tromper
il ya eu des cas spectaculaires bon mais
dans l'ensemble elle fait un bon travail
je pense en tout cas à 35 ans et que ce
soit le gouvernement qui est à la
décision
vous pouvez imaginer tout de suite
imaginé ce pauvre ministre qui doit
décider si on remet en liberté un
criminel qui est en prison depuis 35 ans
imaginez un peu la réaction de la
population
vous le voyez les gens sont extrêmement
sensibles de la ces questions là l'
affaire guy turcotte au québec tu as
très bien démontré je suis en train de
faire une comparaison là sauf que quand
il s'agit de jeu cesse quand on a
l'impression que la justice ne joue pas
bien son rôle donc la commission des
libérations ne joue pas bien son rôle et
a tout de suite sentiment d'insécurité
il ya tout de suite des levées de
boucliers la question qu'il faut se
poser à c'est quand il se fait que dans
ce cas là ce sera le parlement le côté
politique qui prendra la décision finale
alors que sur le terrorisme mais sur un
peu refuse carrément le parlement est un
mot à dire sur la façon dont le scrs et
la grc se comporteront un peu de poids
deux mesures paradoxal en termes
politiques justement tasha est-ce que sa
place par l'opposition par ailleurs dans
une position assez délicate
oui absolument et côte ils vont pas
défendre les meurtriers n'ont pas
défendre les bernado même les lives in
celui qu'ils ont trouvés coupables de
fantômes non pas mentalement parce que
ils savent que la sympathique public
n'est pas avec ces gens là
alors messieurs a été très intelligente
parce que dans le projet y parle aussi
des attentats terroristes et de la haute
trahison
s'ils ont utilisé ces mots là alors il
est il englobe le tout alors en même
temps que peut-être les autres
politiciens de l'opposition aurait dit
écoute ces gens là on peut pas on peut
pas les enfermer à tout prix quand les
met à égalité avec les bernardo du monde
s'avérant très difficile de s'opposer à
ce projet de loi en tout cas et longer
la prochaine élection et bien que oui
exactement exactement est un exemple
intéressant l'ajournement bien sûr on
peut annoncer sur ce projet doit il ya
une députée conservatrice de la région
hors auto qui envoyait d'être assez
compétent pour solliciter des fonds en
vertu de en prévision de la prochaine
campagne électorale et le titre de la
dette c'était des meurtriers dans votre
voisinage
et si vous voulez vous voulez être
protégés contre ccc meurtri la seule
façon c'est de réélire le gouvernement
après alors si vous aviez des doutes sur
les intentions réelles du premier
ministre et c'est très habile je le
reconnais avec tâche assez extrêmement
habile en ce moment en particulier c'est
avant tout électeur à l'espace qui n'est
pas dit plusieurs experts soutiennent
que le projet de loi ne tiendra pas la
route devant la cour super et on veut
que les parties aient des positions
claires on peut certainement pas
reprocher aux conservateurs de ne pas
être clairs dans leurs intentions
ça ça fait partie également de la
stratégie de polariser un peu le débat
est d'avoir des positions claires sont
peut pas leur reprocher aux
conservateurs les premiers de le faire
aussi oui mais c'est un aussi qu'il leur
est cher alors passons à la scène
québécoise maintenant le ministre
couillard veut revoir la rémunération de
nos députés ça débat qu'on a depuis
longtemps en fait et qui a été ravivée
par la démission du ministre bolduc
sébastien vous qui passez beaucoup de
temps avec les députés là ce qu'il faut
revoir leur rémunération assez puissant
vent
il faut certainement faire le débat
c'est un débat qui a été poussé comme la
vieille poussière sous le tapis par tous
les gouvernements depuis belle lurette
et le chaos bolduc ravive ce débat il ya
un rapport indépendant le rapport de
claire l'heureux dubé qui est sur la
table qui doit servir de base et qui
prévoit d'augmenter le salaire des
députés de 90 mille dollars environ 120
milles dollars mais ce n'est pas aussi
simple que ça vous savez c'est pas une
question noir ou blanc est une question
qui se décline en 50 nuance de gris
parce que dans cette rémunération il
faut prendre la rémunération globale les
allocations de transition le fonds de
pension et ainsi de suite
il faut certainement faire le débat vous
savez à l'assemblée nationale comme dans
toutes les fonctions à toutes les
carrières dans tous les métiers il ya
des bons et il ya des mauvais députés
il ya des députés qui mérite cent vingt
mille dollars il ya des députés qui
méritent pas 120 dollars il ya des
députés qui passent leur fin de semaine
à courir les soupers spaghetti les
cercles des fermières
les chevaliers de colomb instituts et
qu'ils mangent et tablettes de chocolat
dans le retour parce que tout simplement
pas le temps de soupe et peut-être que
le gouvernement devrait s'inspirer de la
réponse barrette en santé imposer des
quotas de souper spaghetti ya encore des
chaque année scolaire et surtout et
surtout ses bassins qui n'ont pas
probablement pas le temps d'aller voir
comme vous 50 nuance de quesnoy la nfl
pour marquer votre imaginaire il faut
certainement faire le débat ça c'est sûr
daniel chastement l'accord avec
sébastien est ce que les députés
devraient gagner davantage oui sans
aucun doute
le québec c'est pas une république de
bananes après tout c'est une démocratie
bien vivant tous ces gens là travaillent
très fort ces basses elle a démontré à
le problème c'est qu'à il n'y a pas de
bon moment pour faire ce genre de débats
et encore moins en ce moment à cause ce
débat sur la série ça devrait se faire
comme le recommande le rugby l'ancienne
juge au début d'un nouveau gouvernement
avec l'accord des trois gouvernements de
façon consensuelle pour éviter les
critiques ça s'impose à il ya beaucoup
de cynisme la population beaucoup de
gens vont dire non non non il ne mérite
pas la commission charbonneau commission
gomery avant enfin passer bien des
politiciens pour des corrompus pour en
avoir fréquenté je fais le calcul cet
après-midi pour m'amuser environ 3000
dans ma carrière politique je rejoins
sébastien la plupart font un excellent
travail il ya des mauvais politiciens
comme les des mauvais journalistes les
bras des avocats des bords des
professeurs et ses journalistes d'achat
mais je te question des primes aussi là
parce que c'est ça qui a suscité ce
n'est pas de regarder les primes sont
les annuler tout de suite mais il faut
écouter si on va voir la rémunération
pourrait avoir tous les bénéfices et les
primes et le doubs qui est là et là on
voit que le calcul viêt effet c'est que
si on réussit on augmente les salaires
mais on augmente aussi les contributions
aux pensions jusqu'à 43%
si on réduit les primes de départ comme
celui de monsieur bolduc
là on arrive à un chiffre de cheval ça
coûterait 800 mille dollars pour faire
la réforme globale qui est envisagé
c'est pas énorme et je suis d'accord
écoute vous obtenez sur pourquoi vous
payez si vous payez des salaires qui
sont tellement minal
peut-être n'est pas nécessairement la
qualité de représentation il ya des gens
qui pouvaient gagner beaucoup plus dans
le secteur privé parce que la politique
pas une vocation parc ont par contre
comme certains disent c'est une vraie
question est celle du fait d'une
pression pour ceux qui peuvent se le
permettre non écoute les gens aussi ont
le droit à certains qualité de
rémunération pour le travail qu'ils font
et c'est vrai que ces gens là
travaillent fort on les critique
toujours mais c'est pas un travail
facile et c'est pas un travail je pense
que la majorité de la population
aimerait faire bon il nous reste très
peu de temps donc 10 15 secondes chacun
pourquoi c'est si mal perçue dans la
dans la société
toute cette question d'augmenter le
salaire des députés daniel daniel
écoutez il ya il ya toujours cette
mauvaise cette mauvaise cet état
d'esprit et au québec et c'est vrai
ailleurs aussi que bon plus vous avez de
l'argent puis vous en gagnez pierce et
plus vous êtes mal perçu il ce rapport
un peu amour haine avec l'argent à ccc
viscérale c'est comme ça ça existe
depuis des siècles c'est partout on veut
jamais vu sous un angle plus que nous
ouais le rapport amour-haine très
certainement et c'est de l'argent public
aussi on veut que l'argent soit bien
dépensé que ça rapporte au public
justement et dans certains cas des fois
on peut se questionner battu d'achat le
montant des coûts c'est l'argent des
contribuables finalement il faut la
gérer avec prudence
absolument mais il faut aussi
récompenser le travail et demander le
paiement des pénalités des pensions
aussi qui est du jeu va très bien merci
beaucoup à vous trois merci sébastien
bourdais merci beaucoup